all right joining me now is larry kudlow
host of kudlow on fox business and
former director of the national economic
council under president trump larry it's
great to see you tonight
um
are we in
the biden recession now
well i don't think we're in a recession
right this moment
but i got to tell you
with record high inflation it's going to
be almost impossible to avoid a
recession
and given the fact that there's no
confidence in joe biden and by the way
there's no confidence in fed chair jay
powell
we could wind up with an inflationary
recession which would be the worst of
all possible worlds i mean both of those
guys are trying to whitewash the
inflation problem so what you got now is
market interest rates are rising we had
big wage cost numbers today
real incomes you know real wages after
inflation are falling it's very
difficult consumer confidence is down
small business confidence is down so no
i don't think we're in a recession right
now but as i say i think it'll be
virtually impossible to avoid a
recession um either later this year or
next year now larry here's how one of
biden's economic advisors actually views
the economy today
is this country is this economy in a
position of strength to face what's
coming at us that's the answer if you
look at our job market if you look at
our gdp growth if you uh look at
household how households incomes are
doing how their savings are doing you
would conclude that we are approaching
this moment from a position of strength
larry gdp shrank last month
and inflation is destroying
savings people are getting poorer in the
united states
what are these people talking about and
does this in any way calm the markets
you know
i want to say
jared bernstein is an old friend of mine
and personally he's really a good he's
always i'm sure he i'm sure he saves
kittens from trees larry but this is the
country going down the two i'm i've got
to say i love you and you're one of my
favorite people everyone's friends with
everyone in washington new york we all
love each other we all you know that's
great
our country
is falling apart
and these people are lying about it i
don't think we can you know mince words
at this point they're lying to the
american people
i'm sorry to jump on you but i just i'm
i'm fed up with this
yes i understand but um analytically i
don't know what jared's talking about
because in fact he's talking about
consumer incomes well look consumer
incomes after inflation are falling
and
small business incomes after inflation
are falling so i'm not sure where he's
coming from on this i mean look at
the federal reserve
blew this
a year ago i don't know why jay powell
has been reappointed he certainly uh
doesn't deserve it he has no people do
not have confidence he was out there
yesterday laura and he tried to
whitewash the whole problem he sounded
like joe biden blaming inflation on
vladimir putin and covet that's nonsense
the problem here was too much federal
spending too much federal borrowing and
too much central bank money printing and
the fed has got to stop whitewashing the
problem and go to it otherwise
the longer they wait and the more they
try to avoid these issues which is what
biden is unfortunately doing the worse
the recession is going to be i mean the
worst possible combination is
inflationary recession a double barrel
of poison that's the worst thing you can
have and that's my concern right now
again the fed's not taking action we're
still spending too much in washington
you've got these guys are talking about
raising taxes which should be the worst
thing in the world they should all be
fired is there any one of these people
larry are there any single one yellen
jay powell the the council on economic
advice
do i mean friends and offer should any
of these people be in this position
after they blew off the inflation
concerns that you raised and larry
summers raised a year ago any of them be
still working because in corporate
america they all would have been fired
on a basketball team if they were
coaches they'd be fired
long ago well i'll put it i'll put it a
little more positively you mentioned
larry summers who got this right you met
jason furman got this right i mean i
think
moderate democrats with experience and
some weight should be in this
administration and they should replace a
lot of the economic policymakers and
that's probably true good throughout the
cabinet as you noted in your in your
intro but again i just want to make this
point
the longer they wait to take action to
stop this inflation the worse it's going
to be and the worse the recession is
going to be yeah we got to go there more
working folks are going gonna suffer
against hammering
i'd like to avoid the middle class
getting damaged and hammered as you say
and that's you know stop we gotta get
out watching this own it and change it
now they don't wanna own it they this is
part of their plan i'm actually
believing they're enjoying this moment
larry i love having you on thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else